[Musique]
depuis plusieurs jours partout dans
l'Hexagone de nombreux Français
manifestent contre la réforme des
retraites
[Musique]
fait vivement réagir les citoyens au
sein même du milieu artistique les
artistes qui s'expriment eux là où ils
le peuvent
le rappeur schct déjà exprimé sur les
réseaux sociaux à ce sujet le
gouvernement n'a rien à faire de la voie
du peuple l'utilisation du 49-3 en est
la preuve de 300 célébrités dont
Jonathan Cohen viennent de signer une
lettre ouverte adressée à Emmanuel
Macron en demandant un retrait média de
la réforme mais aujourd'hui certains
jugeant les célébrités peu concernés par
la réforme s'insurge les voir prendre
part à ce débat et dénonce une forme de
démagogie alors manifestation et grève
les stars doivent-elles se prononcer
[Musique]
après en bulle avant qu'on en parle
quand ils font rien on dit qu'il faut
rien quand il faut que les gens on est
toujours des magots
qui parle et je suis en l'occurrence
d'accord avec maintenant je me demande
où ils étaient pendant la crise
sanitaire en fait il ne s'exprime quand
même souvent que quand ça va dans le
sens du vent quand c'est bénéfique
je fais un exemple je dis que il ne
s'exprime que quand c'est quand même
assez pratique et qu'ils ne prennent pas
beaucoup de risques étant donné qu'ils
savent très bien que 70 à 80% de la
population va dans ce sens là là tout
d'un coup on les entend mais quand c'est
impopulaire on ne les entend pas et ce
serait ça le courage le vrai courage une
indication à géométrie variable voilà
absolument non mais moi je pense que
surtout excuse-moi Béatrice le vrai
courage ce serait surtout qu'il descende
dans la rue qui brave la police qui soit
là sous la pluie et qui descendent avec
les grévistes parce que excuse-moi signé
un petit morceau de papier sur une
pétition on va quand même applaudir
Jonathan Cohen et toute la clique des
300 acteurs qui ont signé des morceaux
de papier je trouve qu'il y a aucun
courage à faire ça
une autre époque c'est des femmes
célèbre c'était pas elle passait un bout
de papier pour l'avortement ça aurait
pas inventé
les gens qui manifestent contre la
réforme des retraites ils sont dans la
rue ils y vont on a vu personne
moi je trouve ça bien quand les artistes
s'engagent mais effectivement à chaque
fois qu'il y a des acteurs ou des
personnalités très souvent ça va dans le
côté dans le côté de la bien-pensance et
ça c'est un peu embêtant
ce que d'être à côté de ceux qui
considèrent que cette réforme est un
petit peu difficile à accepter
de faire ça et par exemple ça me fait
penser au gilet jaune au début Franck
Dubosc avait un peu initié le mouvement
ensuite les gilets jaunes c'était plus
trop trop à la mode et donc il y a plein
de personnalités qui qui ne parlaient
plus des gilets jaunes par exemple donc
c'était le mouvement à cause de la
violence bah oui mais bon moi je trouve
que leur tribune est très très juste ils
ont trouvé les mots ils sont pas
forcément concernés donc ils auraient pu
tranquillement voilà ne pas signer du
tout et s'en [__] complètement parce
que les plus connus peut-être mais je
veux dire que l'intermittent du système
justement
à 64 ans
il parle pour ceux qui travaillent avec
eux qui qu'on n'écouterait pas parce que
si les ingénieurs du son avaient fait
une tribune on en parlerait pas
aujourd'hui donc moi je parle pas de
courage parce que vous avez raison sur
le fait que faire une signature c'est
pas un grand courage mais je trouve ça
bien et vraiment il faut la lire elle
est très juste et ils étaient peut-être
un tournage ils ont peut-être pas pu
aller à la manif merci
vous non je dis non ils ont le droit de
s'exprimer bien sûr comme tout le monde
mais je vois pas le faire en quoi le
fait de bien jouer de être un bon
comédien donne plus d'autorité ou de
poids dans le débat sur la forme donc ça
fait longtemps autant les Français que
mais pas plus eux que les Français
quand on est connu c'est un plus
excusez-moi quand une star se mobilise
pour une cause excusez-moi ça a plus
d'écho c'est comme ça et d'influence
qu'on ne connaît pas se servent de
bêtises alors moi je pense que c'est ça
s'exprimer même plus bon on trouve que
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'important
je suis fier de voir des artistes
engagés ils représentent la France et tu
dis que c'est il suivent le fil du temps
et le cours du vent mais je suis
vraiment désolé c'est un sujet brûlant
qui qui casse un petit peu la société
pour l'écologie pour le contre le sida
ou pour des choses comme ça on crie au
génie et là sur des sujets quand même
très très transaxe
t'auras jamais une lettre ouverte des
comédiens qui sont pour la réforme si tu
vois bien qu'ils vont dans le sens du
vent l’inverse n'aura jamais lieu
évidemment bien sûr il y a notre Patrick
Bruel qui s'est exprimait également on
regarde
la réflexion qu'on peut se faire c'est
est-ce qu'il était obligatoire de la
faire maintenant que ce 49-3 soit une
constitutionnelle ça se discute pas et
qu'il soit adressé à des parlementaires
mais en l'occurrence ça peut être les
parlementaires il y a le peuple qui est
dans la rue il y a le peuple qui
s'exprime comment est-ce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas prendre ce ce cette décision
comme comme une offense et je pense que
ça aurait été peut-être intéressant de
en tout cas utile de calmer les choses
de calmer de reprendre le débat de
remettre les choses sur la table et de
repartir à la discussion il y a quelque
chose qui qui a crispé on a on a choisi
une fracture
moi ce que j'aime bien chez Bruel c'est
que il s'est toujours engagé sur les
sujets sociétaux il s'est jamais caché
toujours et après sur le fond on en
pense qu'on veut il y a les pour les
contre mais je trouve que il structure
son argumentaire c'est vraiment bien
c'est poser c'est pas haineux et ça ça
porte de mon point de vue j'ai répondu
oui à tout mais son intervention porte
plus qu'une lettre signée par 300
personnes parce que là je trouve qu'il
touche au cœur les gens est-ce que vous
pensez que le président Macron va être
interpellé d'avoir une lettre de 300
personnes connues
dans la rue il va pas être interpellé
par une petite lettre signée par trois
acteurs d'accord alors il y en a qui
s'exprime aussi comme quoi on peut avoir
été président et avoir été président et
commenter les autres c'est François
Hollande
et courage fuyant regardez
qui vient après une succession d'erreurs
erreur de moments de faire une réforme
des retraites lorsque il y a de
l'inflation une guerre en Ukraine des
préoccupations c'était pas à ce
moment-là que les Français étaient prêts
à comprendre le sens de ce qu'il aurait
été proposé une erreur de de contenu
aussi de demander davantage à ceux qui
travaillent tôt qui travaille dur plutôt
qu'un ceux qui détiennent du patrimoine
ou des hauts revenus ou les employeurs
eux-mêmes une erreur également de
méthode et c'est celle là qui est en
cause d'avoir privilégié un accord
politique en l'occurrence avec une
formation de droite
alors
Béatrice
écoutez que dire
ça se passe de commentaires franchement
qui voilà
raison absolument sur le timing
maintenant qui viennent donner des
leçons après coup après le désastre de
son quinquennat exactement mais je dois
dire franchement c'est ce que je disais
à Daniel le quinquennat actuel en arrive
presque à me faire regretter le sien ce
qui est vraiment
oui bon merci
peut-être que si lui avait pris une
décision forte pendant son quinquennat
décision
de gauche de la femme et des retraites
c'est totalement impossible c'est
mission impossible j'en ai pas beaucoup
mais après c'est toujours facile après
la bataille de refaire l'histoire voilà
et il a été président personne serait
incapable de se souvenir d'une seule
réforme qu'il a faite
nucléaires un mariage
les centrales nucléaires
le mariage pour tous
un président c'est déjà pas si mal
qu'est-ce que vous retiendrez du des
demandes de Monsieur Macron le chaos le
chaos merci allez on va avancer merci
beaucoup pour cette réponse